you all know that I always say don't dfi
politicians these are just people they
are flawed people sometimes they want to
do things we agree with sometimes they
don't but the idea of holding
politicians up and I don't care if it's
the mag a crowd or Bernie or bust or the
Tulsi people or whoever I don't
recommend deifying any politician but
that doesn't mean that there can be real
material important differences between
one politician and another and the civil
unrest and protests that we've been
seeing this week are providing a really
good case study to look at some of the
differences Donald Trump sat at the
White House tweeting threatening to
deploy the military to States and on one
day this week used police to gas
protesters and used horses to disperse
protesters so that he could walk over to
st. John's and get a picture awkwardly
holding a Bible that's what Trump did
meanwhile Joe Biden and Nancy Pelosi and
Elizabeth Warren have actually gone and
met with protesters and talked to
protesters and even marched with
protesters in some cases this doesn't
make them perfect people
it doesn't make Democrats uber
progressive it doesn't make them gods it
doesn't do anything other than show us
there is a really stark contrast right
now in terms of how completely out of
his element and impotent Donald Trump is
how unable to lead the president is that
he can't even do the simple things that
many elected officials are doing
yesterday Nancy Pelosi as we are showing
you on video went out to the protests in
Washington DC spoke to protesters walked
around was part of what was going on
doesn't mean anything in particular
about Nancy Pelosi's policy positions
but it does tell us that she's at least
out there seeing what's going on and
talking to people
does this make Nancy Pelosi some
progressive change maker no she's a
moderately left establishment Democrat
but Trump is hiding out and tweeting
okay it's the contrast that matters
yesterday I told you about Democratic
Massachusetts senator Elizabeth Warren
she went out to participate in a March
on the streets in Washington DC brought
her husband along brought her dog along
we're showing our video audience some
video of that right now and again making
it very clear she was asked why is Trump
sending out the military she said well
because he's wrong
joining protesters talking to people
being out there being part of our
community rather than someone sitting at
the White House in the Oval Office or
even you know in a bunker as Donald
Trump did did briefly on Friday sending
out tweets and mobilizing forces and
putting up fence after fence after fence
says I don't know if you saw but
significant new fencing being erected
around the White House area likewise
Democratic presidential candidate Joe
Biden going out even earlier than Nancy
Pelosi even earlier than Elizabeth
Warren to talk to protesters to
understand what's going on making a
speech about the systemic elements that
are at play in what these protests are
meant to illuminate and and and a deal
with Biden Pelosi and Warren do not
deserve our support just because they
met with protesters we still need to be
thinking critically about every single
one of these individuals and who we vote
for but the point is there's an absolute
total minimum as public officials that
should be done just to show you're even
remotely engaged with what's going on
out there
it is about contrast with Donald Trump
Trump stayed at the White House and
tweeted insults he went to his bunker he
walked over to a church and held up a
Bible that Ivanka Trump carried over for
him in a $1,500 purse for a photo op
after protestors were dispersed with
smoke and huge horses there's just no
comparison in terms of how unfit to lead
the president is this is just the latest
latest example now let's deal with some
of the critiques many of you might no
doubt say okay Biden Warren and Pelosi
they went out there but what have they
actually done and that's a fair question
Biden's not even in an elected position
right now so what can he do other than
say here's what I would do as president
but they are actually there they're in
the midst of what's happening compared
to our easily trigger Abul president who
can't even be bothered to do any work at
this point never mind engage with the
problems that the country is dealing
with in a way that doesn't seem
patronize
or that will actually make the problem
worse I keep going back to one of the
thoughts I keep going back to is the
protests started because of anger about
treatment of black men by police police
using too much force police being too
brutal and what Donald Trump does is say
hey you know what the governors aren't
deploying enough law enforcement force
they're not doing enough shows of
strength I'm going to override them and
send in the military as if more law
enforcement force is the solution to
protests protesting about too much law
enforcement force being used it's
inconceivable there is it's hard to
think of someone more poorly suited to
lead at this point in time coronavirus
already proved it the protests are only
the latest example and we've got five
months we've got five months and we are
ultimately going to decide what happens
next if you love feeding your
intellectual curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time favorite apps called
blinka stinketh lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video